just remember leaving the beach behind
and then driving back to Caracas
it was like hectic everywhere in the
mountains you can see these shanty
houses that was just horrendous I've not
seen that in my life and I thought
Christ I felt like I'd entered a
third-world country that was my country
I shouldn't have been there they took us
to this apartment and the apartment just
look dingy like nothing I'd expected I
[Music]
remember the meeting and thinking reward
you eating the glamour associated with
pop stars you associate that with
cocaine then you look in the apartment
there is no glamour there
it was the most scariest part of my life
in that I've ever experienced
I didn't understand what they was
talking about I didn't understand what
they had in mind I didn't understand
what their next moves were we was
virtually puppets there's no way you
could have argued with them kind of
people you just gotta do what they say
unless you wanted that bullet in your
head you couldn't do anything I was just
there to do what I got to do and then go
I could wait to get out the apartment
just remember feeling like I've got to
do two guys caught me into the room and
I stood there and I'd take my shirt off
[Music]
he produced a vest I just remember being
really really heavy when he put it on my
back it was like and I stood with my
arms out and they put the jacket on me
and I felt the weight put on my
shoulders I knew there was far more in
the jacket and what the Russian guy sent
us to collect they pulled the cords at
the top here sewed the shoulders they
made it so it was tight around your
stomach there was no way that I could
have took this vest off myself I
remember thinking this is where you come
to get kitted up
I remember thinking people have been
here before me but I knew now I was
gonna see for myself I just looked at
myself in the mirror and I thought to
myself would have her got myself into
but it's already on me now they've sold
it up they've paid for my holiday
they paid for everything else it's just
like walking into a brick wall and
there's no there's just one way forward
now there is no turning back
that's it you're there and we waited
till the lady go than not you're okay go
and then they walked us down to the taxi
paid the guy and walked off and that was
the last time we've seen them it feels
like a straitjacket to be honest with
you you can't get out of it but it's
just strapped to you and you can feel
the packages digging into the side of
your ribs and you just want to get it
off as fast as you can I remember Jim
turning around to say to me this stinks
I was scared that people would smell the
drugs on us I was scared that people
were watching us all the way to the
airport was paranoid completely we
stopped talking because we didn't know
the cab driver was in on
if this taxi driver is involved and we
do make a wise move we will get shot
you get outside the airport and you just
see all the police around you in all the
national guards and you think
I was scared but I couldn't show that I
was scared so I was trying to hide it
but just remember my heart pounding and
just feeling skirting it what we gonna
do now